might need fire all of it I want all of
it you want to have hope I want all of
it
I love Sailor Moon I babysat for years
and literally every cent of that money
went to Sailor Moon gear and
paraphernalia I can't think of any other
show where the entire cast of
superheroes is all women teamwork was so
important to Sailor Moon but it was
teamwork that was very woman centered I
would absolutely love to see a Latina
character added into the can I don't
have to see it now you're really great
to see a black girl as the Sailor Scout
like yeah like afro puffs and stuff I
think that'd be really cute actually
what kind of weapon do you want really
long hair that I could turn into a whip
I kind of want her to be wearing like
high boots that have like a killer he'll
look she can do
what kind of superpower him you always
wanted some sort of power with my hair
like if I just had like big hair I could
like hold stuff in it like I don't know
like a ball of energy throw it up hold
something in your hair yeah and what
would you say your weapon would be do
you mean like like a sword making that
even it can be whatever you want I don't
know 10 like a pen but the pen is my
idea I definitely want a scepter 10%
flirty but like 90% badass why not 100%
badass no I'm only gotta be real we're
recreating me not the ideal
close your eyes okay look
yes oh my god it's so cute holy [ __ ]
what a fierce badass [ __ ] I'm like bad
girl and I like it she got the two
piercings they're one of the
characteristics I celebrate the most she
even has my like angry face Brown I've
got a star in my hair I can throw it and
kill someone new pogs sceptre yes if
you're out there animators you should
get on this right now but I think that
would be great for a little girl to see
a superhero that has afro puffs just
like hers looking at myself painted as a
superhero really fulfills a part of my
childhood that was always a little empty
there's something so cool about seeing
yourself so perfectly represented as
like this badass superhero that makes me
want to aspire to like be that the way
she spring into life she's got these two
weapons but she also has a smile on her
face like just because she's fierce and
powerful doesn't mean that she's any
less beautiful celebrating those things
and showing that they can be married is
one of the greatest strengths of Sailor
Moon in fact it makes them more
beautiful the more powerful they are